dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here if we
have an animation movie or a computer
game with quadrupeds and we are yearning
for really high-quality lifelike
animations
motion capture is often the go-to tool
for that motion capture means that we
put an actor in our case a dog in the
studio we ask it to perform sitting
trotting pacing and jumping record its
motion and transfer it onto our virtual
character this generally works quite
well however there are many difficulties
with this process we will skip over the
fact that an artist or engineer has to
clean and label the recorded data which
is quite labor-intensive but there is a
bigger problem we have all these
individual motion types at our disposal
however a virtual character will also
need to be able to transition between
these motions in a smooth and natural
manner recording all possible
transitions between these moves is not
feasible so in an earlier work we looked
at a neural network based technique to
try to weave these motions together for
the first sight
this looks great however have a look at
these weird sliding motions that it
produces do you see them they look quite
unnatural this new method tries to
address this problem but ends up
offering much much more than that it
requires only one hour of motion capture
data and we have only around 30 seconds
of footage for jumping motions which is
basically next to nothing and this
technique can deal with unstructured
data meaning that it doesn't require
manual labeling of the individual motion
types which saves a ton of work hours
beyond that as we control this character
in the game this technique also uses a
prediction network to guess the next
motion type and the gating network that
helps blending together these different
motion types both of these units are
neural networks on the right you see the
results with the new method compared to
a standard neural network based solution
on the left make sure to pay special
attention to the foot sliding issues
with the solution on the left and note
that the new method doesn't produce any
of those now these mo
look great but they all take place on a
flat surface you see here that this new
technique excels at much more
challenging landscapes as well
this technique is a total powerhouse and
I can only imagine how many workers this
will say four artists working in the
industry it is also scientifically
interesting and quite practical my
favorite combination it is also well
evaluated so make sure to have a look at
the paper for more details thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
you